non mais d'accord non mais arrêtez de
tout confondre c'est pas possible le
Mozart de la finance c'est comme ça que
on vous avait présenté à un bilan
économique qui est très mauvais vous
dépendez du pouvoir russe vous ne parlez
pas à d'autres dirigeants vous parlez à
votre banquier quand vous parlez de la
Russie je vous ai retrouvé un tweet que
j'avais fait le 9 novembre 2014 je
soutiens une Ukraine libre qui ne soit
soumise ni aux États-Unis ni à l'Union
européenne ni à la Russie vous êtes
climato-sceptique vous vous êtes un peu
climato hypocrite le marché européen
finito
ce soir Madame Le Pen on peut décider de
ripoliner tout seul la façade la réforme
que vous proposez est une réforme qui
consiste à payer les professeurs en
fonction des résultats de leurs élèves
je sais pas c'est McKinsey qui a proposé
ça y est j'attendais celle-là mais vous
allez créer la guerre civile si je vous
le dis en toute sincérité et pendant
votre quinquennat Emmanuel Macron vous
aurez attendu les cris il n'y a que les
crises qui arrivent à vous faire bouger
en vrai